so when you read Boris is referring to
here I can resonate with a lot of it and
reading about the Prime Minister's fight
brings it all back for Darren and his
family this was Darren five weeks ago he
just left hospital having survived kovat
19 like Boris Johnson he was taken to
intensive care nurses told him he had 15
minutes to call those closest to him I
was struggling to even dialed the
numbers on my phone going to the memory
bank pick out people's numbers bring
family ring friends it was just awful
having to explain I'd cried and I begged
the doctors and the nurses prior not to
let me die
you know I pleaded I begged and then
having to say to Angela my parents my
brothers my sister family friends that
this could be my last conversation I
love them it was very emotional very
distressing and I just sat there crying
I just collapsed to the floor I didn't I
couldn't function okay as soon as I put
the fire down from him it was like I
love you I love you
put the phone down and then I drink
again and it was like I needed to speak
to him constantly before they put him
under a short time later Darren was put
into a coma and onto a ventilator the
one nurse she looked me in the eye and
she said don't you worry we will save
you and she was struck in my arm and I
remember her saying to me count to 10
and I think I got 2 3 I may never wake
up now that could be me gone luckily I
did and I came out the other side but
what he witnessed won't go away and
seeing other people in intensive care
for the two days when I was
semi-conscious hearing the machines seen
the people just lying there with pipes
pumps machines keeping them alive was
just awful to see and it's probably
images that stay with me
now and maybe forever
and Darren like the Prime Minister will
always count himself amongst the lucky
ones
Lisa Dowd Sky News Staffordshire